good morning welcome to Edna
we are starting with our first Senate
bills and I call on Senate Bill 45 and I
good morning Madam chair and good
morning honorable members of the House
Edna committee for the record my name is
Sharon Carson and I have the pleasure of
representing Senate District 14
comprising the towns of Londonderry
Hudson and Auburn and I have for your
consideration this morning Senate Bill
45 relative to National Guard education
benefits
Madam chair
um this bill is quite frankly fairly
simple and builds upon legislation that
was passed within last biennium which
would allow National Guard eligible
National Guard members to transfer their
educational benefits to their spouse
this is can be seen as a recruitment
tool for the National Guard and if the
member is not interested in attending
college
that it will allow their spouse to
attend a four-year state or College
University with their benefits and
that's it
thank you thank you very much Madam
chair if if I may ask as I read this the
spousal
benefit is already in statute and what
they added was the ability to use it at
the University system in addition to the
community college system correct that is
correct
um and
um
like having a brain cramp here
um you are absolutely correct it does
allow them to have access to
our University of New Hampshire and I
believe there's someone here from the
University system who will testify in
favor they did testify in favor in the
Senate as well
thank you yes I've got other are there
any other questions from the committee
representative Simon thank you madam
chair so this would allow both the
spouse and the serving member the
benefit of a four-year or just one or
the other
um to be honest representative I'm not
sure okay
um it's usually what happens is you
might have a National Guard member who
already has a college degree and doesn't
want to go for an advanced degree and I
don't believe they pay for an advanced
degree
um but they're not going to use that
benefit so this is going to allow their
spouse to use the benefit I'm not sure
if both of them can and again there's uh
uh Mr Perry lines nine and ten lines
nine and ten would be my question yeah
okay let's see um members
yeah you can it can go back it looks
not at the same time thank you all right
any other questions representative thank
you I think you sort of answered this
but just to be completely clear the only
change this bill is doing is uh is
adding to the current benefit of being
able to use the community college system
to be able to use the university system
as well and everything else stays the
same everything else stays the same
representative all right thank you okay
the other question
thank you Senator thank you
Madam chair members of the committee for
the record my name is Warren Perry I'm
the deputy adjun general for New
Hampshire's Department of military
Affairs and veteran services
and we thank you for the opportunity to
speak on behalf of the uh of this of
Senate Bill 45 uh relative to National
Guard education benefits
as many of you may know the top
strategic challenge for the New
Hampshire National Guard remains
Recruitment and Retention for the next
generation of our service members in our
Armed Forces what this bill does very
simply is adds another tool in our
toolkit to help retain soldiers so after
they complete their first term Of
Enlistment they have the ability to
transfer their education benefits which
have been existing in statute for a long
time to their spouse and for clarity
it's one or the other at a time they can
transfer back and forth but only one can
use them at a time this is a tremendous
benefit for the members of the National
Guard that they can continue to pursue
higher education uh
essentially for free so it's a it's a
tremendous benefit so what we find is
when we recruit this Soldier we retain
the family so this is a an opportunity
for us to continue to retain soldiers
uh
subject to your questions it's it's
really that simple we we appreciate the
partnership with both the community
college system of New Hampshire and the
university system of New Hampshire but
I'm happy to answer any questions that
you may have a very simple housekeeping
Booth thank you representative Schmidt
thank you ma'am chairman
um so why not both people at the same
time
I think it's uh I think it's just easier
to administer the program for us I mean
there's no reason that we couldn't do it
both at the same time the agreement that
we have with the community college
system when we instituted this in the
last legislation legislative session was
that we would do one or the other
to to not overburden the system because
I mean nobody pays for this right it's
uh you know somebody goes to school for
free it's a it's a it's a sunk cost an
opportunity cost for the University
system I think it's just and it it
doesn't double the demand on the on the
University system I think another reason
would be not everybody needs to go to
school right so so there's no real need
for there to be both I think so follow
up
I I having taught at UNH a number of
years ago uh I know that you know the
university offers the benefit if I want
to take a course myself uh I can just
ask the instructor and as long as he or
she is not you know overburdened for
space or whatever uh they're happy to
oblige but the situation is uh you may
have somebody who is assigned uh I
understand this National Guard it's not
the same being transferred away from if
you're in the Air Force or the Marines
or whatever get transferred away you
lose the opportunity to go to
UNH hypothetically
um but but uh
it it seems to me that would be a
benefit that that would if they can both
get away at the same time and they want
to go they have the advantage of
note-taking all the advantages of being
at the place with a with a companion a
fellow student
I think the department would be opposed
to that I just it's not the way we
envisioned the bill originally
representative
but you're not basically opposing it
either no I'm I'm not I'm not going to
come down either way I think that you
know and I'll let the the university
system kind of comment on any impacts
they have to the university system you
know to our to our way of thinking
transferring the benefit is it's this
it's similar to transferring one's GI
Bill benefits right so when when uh in
the post 911 GI Bill members of the
service could transfer their GI benefits
to a family member could it be a child
or a spouse or whoever they want to be
but you only had so many years of
Eligibility right so many months 36
months of eligibility for your GI bill
so if you transferred some of that away
it was gone you couldn't use it again
and I think we modeled this legislation
on that model would we be opposed to
saying you could do them both at the
same time I wouldn't be opposed to it I
have no idea it didn't really give it
much thought on what the implications
would be the university system thank you
very much
representative
thank you and thank you
may have implied the answer to this
earlier but uh you know everything costs
something so the question and I don't
see a fiscal note to pay for this so is
uh is it just the university system
either Community College or
UNH have to just absorb the cost is that
how it works my understanding is that
they absorb the cost in the in previous
versions of the legislation the the cost
was it was the the uh the benefit was
offered on a space available basis that
changed probably two or three
legislative sessions ago uh I do know
that the university system and the
community college system calculates the
cost the the the the opportunity cost of
this uh I don't have that in front of me
but I know that we they do calculate it
but it doesn't add a burden it just is
lost Revenue I guess what I what I would
say
okay thank you we do have the university
system ready to explain that to us and
the other representative Simon thank you
madam chair um
this isn't specifically to the addition
but just trying to understand the law as
a general rule it says that the member
would be required a four-year reserve
duty service obligation from the date
that the benefit is transferred right
but then the spouse can transfer that
benefit back is there an additional four
years or is it just a one-time so so
when when the member is using the
benefit himself he just has to be a
member in good standing of the National
Guard so it doesn't incur another
service obligation just a member of good
in good standing so if they separate
from the military or they have some
pending uh some reason that they're not
not uh in favorably serving like in good
standing weight control is one of the
things you're not making military
standards then you would not be eligible
for the benefit so there would not be
another service obligation if it went
back to this to the service member and
again it's about retention right so the
guy guy or gal finishes their first term
Of Enlistment we want them to re-enlist
we tell them that their wife or their
husband can go to school for free if
they re-enlist then we get them for
another four years right that's that's
right that's that's the the very pointed
way of saying right yeah thank you
encourage continued service
I don't see any more questions so thank
you very much thank you and I think that
leads into the university
good morning Madam chair and members of
the Edna committee for the record my
name is Catherine provencher I service
the chief administrative officer for our
state's University system of the
University system is in favor of
supporting Senate Bill 45 we testified
to that as Senator Carson mentioned in
the Senate I provided some written
testimony for you and for the record I
passed that out earlier it was part of
our public Mission we've been supporting
National Guards men and women since 1996
over the last decade we've provided
educational benefits to over 7 000
National Guardsmen and women we do
calculate the cost if you will and and
the university system and the community
college system absorb that because it's
part of our public Mission last Academic
Year that was about 2.6 million dollars
in tuition waivers averaging about
seventy three hundred dollars per
um guard's been a woman that took
advantage of the benefit
um
to answer questions on the fiscal note
honestly we aren't sure how
um how many spouses may take advantage
of this benefit
and I don't know the cost if we provided
the benefit to both at the same time so
again this is I believe
and um the deputy in general would know
better than I I think this passed in the
last legislative session
for the community college system and
because of the timing of the University
system wasn't asked to to be included in
the bill and so we were happy to support
it this this session in Senate bill 45.
okay thank you and and thank you for the
numbers we always appreciate those uh
is as I read this this would apply to
any degree granting curriculum including
graduate work
is that true I believe so yes okay thank
you other questions
representative shrew
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question ma'am
um so if uh if a spouse would have to
take advantage of this and go to a
school at unh
full time what is is that cost 7 300
what was that cost
um in-state tuition at the University of
New Hampshire I believe is about fifteen
thousand
right
follow up thank you madam chair and this
would apply to a spouse that
just wanted to take a few courses uh
online or whatever yes thank you
hey
you know I'm sure the uh the range is
from somebody taking one course at
Plymouth state to somebody full time at
UNH it's it's not a flat benefit
correct that's why the average is is 7
300 but 7 300.
any other questions
thank you
um does the University of New Hampshire
current system currently offer this type
of program for some reason I thought you
this was already part of your
it is for National Guards men and women
yes what we haven't had in the past is
this lot for the benefit to be
transferred to a spouse regards men or
woman is not using the benefit okay I
understand thank you
other questions
okay thank you very much thank you
good morning
for the record my name is Paul Lloyd I'm
the chairman of the state veterans
that's fact unanimously supports this
bill
we supported SB 360 last session
ultimately amended to just include the
community college system
this bill includes the university system
Manning the guard is about making sure
we recruit enough people to fill the
ranks and then retaining them
since only the member or spouse can be
enrolled in school with a tuition waiver
the additional cost should be minimal
it's a win-win for the guard and New
Hampshire
we retain we retain a trained guard
member and the spouse gets a degree
opportunity that may help us retain the
family
in our New Hampshire community
retaining someone until their late 20s
early 30s increases likelihood that
family stays in New Hampshire and the
member continues to serve
at svac we know that all military
families know when one of us serves the
whole family serves this is an easy way
for us to acknowledge the importance of
spouses in terms of retaining members
and keep keeping them in state
thank you
thank you very much are there any
questions
representative Schmidt
thank you madam chair could you just
State your affiliation again sir Mr Lord
I'm I'm the chairman of the state
veterans advisory committee State
Veterans of May thank you yes anyone
else
all right don't see any thank you very
much
is there anyone else who wishes to
seeing none I'll close the hearing
and go into the executive session does
representative blackis
is there a second second
representative Gould
all right do you wish to speak to your
motion
I don't know that there's too much more
to say it sounds like uh
you know helping helping the spouse
getting an education will help the
family in general and as I said should
help recruitment okay
for example do you wish to speak to your
second just as a as the daughter of a
former National Guard member I really
appreciate this thank you okay
anyone else all right I'd like to say
that I've very appreciative of the
University system for doing this and the
reason we don't have a fiscal note is
that the
operating budget of unh or the community
college system is not in our our budget
things
having enjoyed the finance committee on
Monday that was made obvious
all right anyone else have a comment
question
all right seeing none the motion is
ought to pass by representative leckis
and the clerk can call the old
representative Simon yes representative
Lucas yes representative Bailey yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan true uh yes
representative Weber yes representative
Gerhard yes clerk votes yes
representative grotta yes representative
Schmidt yes representative goalie yes
representative schuett yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative
gold yes
and the chair yes
sent
okay seeing none will
and representative like I said to your
very earliest convenience
okay
all right that ends the executive
session we have 10 minutes before the
he's done speaking
I forgot about pink cards we don't do
that in the Senate so I will make sure I
get it to you Senator it hasn't been
that long so how quick how quickly we
forget right
um age I'm gonna blame age for that okay
um thank you uh committee members for
taking my testimony on on
um Senate Bill 96. uh this bill was
brought uh as as a request of a
constituent
um the short version of the bill is
about fairness right so the whole
purpose of the bill is to make sure that
public entities that submit rfps don't
put language into an RFP that steers
um a contract to a specific company
because they have specific problems who
is this
policy
only extended to the state energy
performance Contracting why not other
sure so again it was about an identified
identified issue is why this was brought
up is that in some of the state
performance contracts there were some
energy performance contracts there were
some proprietary information written
into the contract that was steering the
the contracts in a given Direction and
all right well I guess that's the
obvious question to
have a follow-up question follow-up yes
so if this was targeted to a specific
issue to do with energy performance
Contracting how do we know that this
issue is not being
how do we address this issue if it's
being
um
used for other types of Contracting do
we know that
I don't have an answer for that again I
take one problem at one time and this is
the problem that was put in front of me
and I looked to correct
and in the state we use the distinct
that distinction to say if it's a bid
we're looking strictly at price and if
it's a proposal we're looking at more
than price so bid would be used for
things that are
um you know we're buying a box of
pencils and they're all the same pencils
we're just looking for the cheapest ones
where um an RFP would be a proposal for
more of a service type so you're looking
for different qualities in the company
um and I have a question these uh Energy
Efficiency contracts are for state-owned
buildings for the most part or
state-owned facilities so the ones that
go through my office the division of
plant property are all for state-owned
buildings
um municipalities as well as school
districts are also allowed to use this
process however as you mentioned earlier
they're not required to follow the state
um rules and laws that guide it yeah
anyone else
all right seeing none thank you very
does anyone else wish to testify on
representative Schmidt
no no okay representative Goulds okay
got in ahead all right perhaps I'm Gould
as I said before having participated in
the process and
um knowing the Integrity this build just
follows suit and I support it gold
click and call the roll
representative Simon yes representative
lakis yes representative Bailey yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative baber yes
representative Gerhard yes clerk vote
Yes representative groda yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
schuett yes representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes and the chair
yes
16 years
all right the motion passes 16-0 and the
objections to consent
okay I will let go representative
lekkus's comment that I'm surprised that
this is necessary and uh I would hope
that the general procurement statutes
are more specific about how about the
fairness required
okay
do you want a report on this yes please
and I promise you I'll follow through
this I promise you I'll follow through
this time thank you very much please uh
report
at your earliest convenience and we have
15 minutes this time
and I will go through those changes
first this would be applicable to large
fabricated items instead of small items
such as nuts bolts and hinges
secondly this would only be applicable
to State projects not maintenance
projects that are 100 million excuse me
one million dollars or more
third state-funded contracts would have
to identify steel products in the
project documents so that all bidders
are aware of the requirements and
finally a procedure would be set up with
the New Hampshire administrative
services to allow for waivers when there
are Supply chains or availability issues
Madam chair I will I will end my
testimony at this point there are
members from the steel industry that are
here that would be able to answer your
questions much better than I can so I
appreciate your time this morning and
thank you very much thank you senator
not taking questions that's fine it
looks like you've got a full staff
behind you
thank you madam chair members of the
committee for the record my name is Dan
McGuire I represent the town of Epsom
um I'm in favor of this bill
um mostly because for very different
reasons I think from others in that this
is really horrible policy and so
anything that reduces really horrible
policy seems to me to be a good thing I
hand it out to you a short article a
couple pages from Professor Boudreau
that talks about why this is bad policy
um but but in a nutshell
protectionism is not a good idea when
when we try
there's a concept in economics of the
scene and the Unseen when you have some
kind of policy like this it's easy to
see who benefits right the people who
benefit are the people in the steel
industry right but the people who are
hurt are sort of invisible because the
people who are hurt are the people who's
who would have a job or would have
higher income otherwise right that if
the if this policy wasn't in place and
they're they're sort of two kinds of of
people like that one is in the in the
steel industry itself let's suppose that
a steel job moved overseas right so so
um because somebody overseas could make
steel cheaper than than we can
um so the money we send overseas has to
come back to the U.S and be paid to
somebody who can do something better
than somebody overseas can do that other
thing somebody in the lumber industry or
somebody in the computer industry or
somebody in the movie industry or
whatever right those are the Unseen
people and if if our funds don't go to
the steel producer overseas then that
overseas person can't can't get the
funds back to us in the sense right so
so
um that's that's the one loss is the
people that would normally have sold to
the overseas people and don't right but
they're invisible the same thing is the
domestic consumers so let's say we
because of this policy spend two dollars
for steel when otherwise if we bought it
overseas we'd spend a dollar
well we have a dollar less right we're
buying steel for two dollars and if we
could have bought it for a dollar we'd
have a dollar more and some of that
dollar more would go to domestic
producers of something else right so
those are unseen people if you see what
I mean so so
protectionist policy like this is is
simply a bad idea but it it feels good
because it's obvious who's being helped
right we can see the steel you know the
poor steel person is losing their job
but what we don't see is all the people
who are losing their jobs as a
consequence of this policy
thank you madam chair
thank you are there any questions
thank you madam chairman and committee
members for the record my name's Gary
Abbott I'm the Executive Vice President
of the associated
excuse me associated general contractors
of New Hampshire
I represent both building and Highway
commercial contractors and
subcontractors and even some suppliers
I appreciate
the sponsor putting this bill in she did
Cover the pretty much the four items
that I have here that we've highlighted
understand that I represent the
commercial construction industry who
deals with this currently
both on Airport projects they deal with
it with Federal projects Highway
projects there has been a buy America
steel provision for many years on those
projects that have Federal requirements
and so last year the legislature adopted
the policy of buy America Steel
the language was vague I know our
industry me representing contractors had
difficulty explaining what this applies
to and what it does not apply to
I think the consensus through that
process was we were talking about
fabricated steel uh the larger items the
larger pieces on construction projects
not the small items that you get at Home
Depot that kind of thing be very hard to
track or even purchase buy American
Steel products for hinges that kind of
thing you got to think of a building
project and all the suppliers and
companies that work on it so what this
bill does and there's some key points
the clarification when you read those
items they are somewhat Technical and
construction related cheers does not
mean like chairs we're sitting in
they're chairs for the rebar that goes
into sidewalks it's a little it's a
different it's a different chairs I know
some have read this bill that language I
have to tell you I got from Federal
Highway it was one of their
clarifications of what the Buy America
steal so we want to duplicate what is
happening with the federal projects in
the state projects so we're playing on
the same Level Playing Field is what
we're talking about by America so that
was part of the definitions really used
a Federal Highway memo that did a
clarification we agreed it was for
larger projects the 1 million and over
make sense and it kind of ties in within
the third bullet point that I have is
you need it in the project you want
every bidder knowing what items we're
talking about this is one of the things
the contractors brought to me that they
know what a Bridge Project what items
we're talking about if you do an airport
project they tell you what items
we're talking about so we want the same
thing here in the state if you have a
state on a state project it should be in
the project documents now this helps
both sides whether you're a steel
fabricator or a contractor bidding the
job you know what items you've got to
make sure are by America so everybody's
on the same Level Playing Field you
don't have somebody coming in who says I
don't know the law
and so I didn't follow the law this
would make it uh not competitive for a
contractor in New Hampshire who knew the
law so it needs to be in the contract
documents and that's what this does the
fourth bullet that was not in the
language that was passed it left it up
to the court system to here disputes if
anybody objected any person said I don't
think you met the by America even with
the definitions being as vague as it is
you had to go to court to resolve it
we think the power should be with
administrative services on state
projects whether it's a wave or whether
there's an issue with a project that way
both the contractor or supplier could
highlight this before the Project's bid
that's our hope is that all this is
resolved ahead of time especially if we
have supply chain issues as we currently
do if there is a problem getting some
item identified administrative Services
would be the oversight makes sense this
applies to just State projects
so with that I would hope the committee
would support and I really look at this
as clarification
of the bill that you passed last year
that set the policy without the details
and the reason the details weren't
completely worked out
the bill changed shape in the last week
during the committee conference it had
some of these items in it those were
removed so we're here today to try to
get that back so with that I would
answer any questions and hope the
committee supports this bill
thank you I remember having the Das
uh allowing waivers in the version of
the bill that we passed it was there but
it went away in the last version that
went and got tacked on to the crypto
bill
ah
thank you very much I wasn't aware of
where it and went to stray are there any
other questions from the committee
representative a bear
before this thank you madam chair before
this one million dollar change what was
it before this
really wasn't clarified in the bill and
that's where the confusion of what items
there's a lot of Steel components in I
think it started with a million I
believe oh it did originally
I think if you look at the statute today
it's not it's not there ah yes when this
committee passed it last year it did
have a threshold of I believe a million
dollars was the amount yeah there were
components your committee saw that was
still there and uh we were happy with
what the senate had passed so we didn't
play a very big role last year as you
were deciding the policy question we
were neutral on the policy question but
just it just is how the process worked
that some of these things got removed
so my follow-up question
is that before the nuts and bolts and
everything in
throughout lines 6 through 10 were not
included this is added in this version
I will I will repeat with the chairman
it was in the Senate version that came
across the Senate amended it with that
nuts and bolts version and some of these
other parts you looked at it you played
with a part that was not that's no
longer in here there was a 25 and I know
this committee had a whole thing there
was some threshold of an amount but I
think when you give it to administrative
Services it solves that so that's not
there there was a piece that your
committee did amend
but I think what we're saying is all of
this was in the original bills it just
the last week it got changed out to a
different version ah I will remind the
committee that you have received a
research report on this topic that uh
it appears not all of us have read as
thoroughly as it deserves
I certainly didn't so I'm surprised to
any other questions
represent true and then representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question so I'm just
trying to get a handle on what
structural steel is in this bill
so is that's
the bid is out to uh to put in a new
bridge
and to pave uh 100 yards on each side of
the bridge so it's the huge i-beams
going in to be the fabricate yeah the
fabricated steel portion and in this
bill you'll see it's the latest edition
of the American Institute of Steel and
it's the fabrication portion that is
that would be covered under this that
follow up thank you madam chair and
the million dollar threshold
is not a million dollars of structural
steel
it's a million dollars of the whole bid
and there may be a hundred thousand
dollars worth of structural steel that's
correct any project that's over a
million is is what's classified here not
a million dollars of fabricated steel
thank you it's really to eliminate when
the state goes out and hires a
subcontractor to fix the plumbing in the
Legislative Office it's not intended for
replenishment
thank you madam chair so I remember
having the bill and and it's got you
know a million different little
qualifications and so forth
so but the bottom line is we're not
talking about people making steel right
we're talking about people making things
out of steel and where you get the steel
is has nothing to do with uh whether
it's American or not is that correct
well it's a process
um it is from the molten stage in the
United States to the fabricator made as
the state it's the steel it is both you
have to show that it was the molten
steel was made in the United States and
then went to the fabricator to make the
product make the size beam say let's
just say a bridge beam of whatever size
bridge I need they would make it and so
there would be a it would be a buy
America from that point it's just not I
went to the local Home Depot and that
qualifies that does not qualify as a buy
America
thank you any other questions
thank you very much and I really
appreciate your summary of what this
this bill does thank you
and
thank you madam chair
um Amy Charbonneau from Continental
Paving
um Gary did a great job summarizing I
guess I'm just wanted to come up as an
end user of the what is written for the
state as a contract so the RSA would
fall down on us as a contractor
um we support family business in New
Hampshire and we had nothing against the
bill from the beginning all we needed
was the clarification
um so the important part of the bid
process is what would play really
important to us and to answer your
question so what it would do is give the
opportunity for the steel manufacturers
to keep the state honest and for us
people to be able to bid honestly so
when a bid comes out they have a list of
items and currently right now the items
are listed and you actually know
particularly like down to the
nitty-gritty each item that has that's
in the job and it would list which ones
have to be made in the United States and
at that point it would give the steel
people the ability to
um ask questions to the the state and
the bidding process if they missed an
item but it also gives the unit like
uniformity in a bid there can be a lot
of confusion when especially
out-of-staters come in and New Hampshire
people know the rule and you can lose a
New Hampshire company could lose a bid
on based on doing it by the way it's
written now and not having Clarity and
it leaves the dot in my eyes a lot of
uncertainty after the fact to try and
imply these rules onto somebody who
didn't know them so I think it causes a
lot of confusion in the bidding process
could cost a lot of money to the dot and
then second
when it plays through if this was were
not to pass out on the job it can cause
a lot of delays and a lot of confusion
again because what items can you go in
the middle of building a bridge you
can't like the certs and the paperwork
and all that takes so many people in
your office and without the clarity we
are unable to really do what we're
supposed to be doing so we're just
asking for the clarification and the
support to be able to do our job every
day for the state most efficiently and
low cost that we possibly can so that's
all I had to say if anybody has any
questions
thank you
I think you covered everything admirably
good morning Madam chair and committee
members I'm Holly novletski I'm
structural steel fabricator located in
Greenland New Hampshire and I'm
um accompanied by some of my other
fabricator uh members from New Hampshire
we do support this bill that AGC brought
forward I think it provides needed
clarification to the bill that was
passed last year and we just want to
provide our support
thank you
appreciate that are there questions
does anyone else wish to testify on
House Bill 195.
okay seeing not all Clues the hearing
does someone have emotion
I do okay representative yes I move auto
pass on Senate bill 195. is there a
second second
okay second by representative goalie you
should speak to your motion I do thank
you madam chair
um last year the house passed this
policy
and I view this bill as a clarification
and an assistance in in the bidding
process
and that's basically
why I moved to Auto pass all right
represent goalie
thank you madam chair I think it
provides the much needed clarification
that these folks are looking for and
support it thank you all right anyone
else
all right seeing non-themotion is ought
oh excuse me please forgive me
representative true and which bill
um was it that
the house passed last year was it 438 or
I have I I know the answer if you don't
mind so we passed Health bill Senate it
was Senate Bill 438 that came over to
the house
all right and then we passed that
and we had amended it to include some of
the million dollar components and then
when it went back to the Senate
um there was a committee of conference
and these the bill was attached to House
Bill 1552 I believe which was a
cryptocurrency bill
and um
the some of the components of the
original Senate bill that came to us had
not been added and the part that is
specifically missing is the part that's
in this Senate bill now online
um yeah
yeah line ten you the part that's bolded
that should have been in the the amended
version on House Bill 1552 during the
committee of conference but it was not
added and that's how that's why we are
here today we're just basically fixing
something that should have been correct
both the Senate bills sorry 1503 I got
the wrong bill yeah sorry both the
Senate bill and the house bill
were amended with a totally different
place and the the Senate bill that we
fixed had a major
at a non-germain Amendment added that
caused it to the Senate to non-concur so
that that language died and that they
added it back into a house bill
irrelevant a different house bill with
no relation to it but they added their
anyone else confused representative shua
thank you madam chair I
if you haven't had time to read the
research paper it it got very convoluted
last year but this explains it very well
and I think you'd have a deeper
understanding
yes it definitely got convoluted
okay
this time the emotion is ought to pass
by representative and the clerk can call
the rule
representative Simon yes representative
Lucas yes representative Bailey yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative a bear yes
representative Gerhard yes clerk vote
Yes representative groda yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
shrewitt yes representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes and the chair
yes
16 a zero name
all right the motion passes 16 to zero
is there any objection to consent
all right seeing none we'll put this one
on consent
what the the fiscal impact is
indeterminable but probably small
um
I think I don't think that's enough to
all right
okay that's uh that's all we have for
this morning
thank you all for your hard work and
efficiency and the we will resume at 1pm
sure
um and and FEMA homeland security has
one too so you can pick either one and
put them with the kits in fact you can
build these any way you want or you can
buy a pre-made kit
uh list so I want to read something and
I'm going to share a copy of this letter
with all of you and then I will finish
up my testimony this is from David Hurst
she's a resident of Bedford New
Hampshire he's an emergency medical
physician that actually works in the
North country and Dr Hersh and I used to
work together at Concord Hospital for a
number of years
he was not able to be here today but he
wanted to share with you and this is key
almost 10 years ago I had the
unfortunate opportunity to experience
firsthand how immediate Hemorrhage
control can save lives I was stationed
at the finish line of the medical tent
for the Boston Marathon bombing and was
one of the first Rescuers to arrive at
the bombing site within minutes of the
blast
although this was a terrible tragedy
with 280 victims and three immediate
fatalities I learned how immediate
bleeding control could help save lives
of everyone that was transported to the
hospital
there was a there was also a large
contribution from bystanders many
without prior medical training some with
but they had to rely on improvised
devices t-shirts and belts they didn't
have these they didn't have kits that
were already pre-prepared not all
incidents that were that cause
uncontrolled Hemorrhage are incidents
that involve you know penetrating trauma
or a bombing or a shooting or a stabbing
it can be quite simply but very scary
broken glass if in the wrong place you
know it's ever an artery and again
someone could bleed to death in under
five minutes
so I've included in this bill limited
liability it's the same Protection One
Would experience under the Good
Samaritan law if they have to act I've
also included it here making a
connection it's not required but they
could connect with the local emergency
department Physicians who work with EMS
and might have a preference you know
might be able to guide them on this is
what you should here's some equipment
and here's what you you can buy it's
um
these kits if you put them together it
can span anywhere from 23 to 83 dollars
that's why you see a variation in the
fiscal note
this bill also puts a dedicated Fund in
place so that
as we move forward if folks want to
contribute you know if there was a group
that wanted to make a contribution so
that we could put these in more of the
public you know more state buildings and
grow this program there would be a place
for this money to actually go we did
this with the AED commission that I'm
now going to date myself that I was a
part of when I worked at the Bureau of
EMS oh gosh in in the um the late 2000s
so we've done us we have done this kind
of work before I also
um set up and this is where the bill had
gotten amended in the committee in the
Senate Edna set up a committee that has
one person from EMS one first doctor
from the medical control board that's
authorized in statute and a member of
administrative services that can take
this list and
set up set the criteria for basically
triage like what buildings would go
first because that's you know what's
going to be hard to sort out so let's
let the experts that would be enabled in
the statute to do this and that's um
yeah the three-person committee and I
think that that's it for now I'll share
Dr Hirsch's letter I do appreciate the
opportunity I'm happy to answer any
questions you have if I can I do have
with me some members of the Emergency
Medical Services community and one of my
co-sponsors here that are available as
well and I'm sorry I have to keep
tipping over this way but I've got this
speaker
it's good thank you chairman okay thank
you Senator are there questions from the
committee representative Gould
thank you Adam Sharon thank you Senator
Apprentice for taking my question I
believe I saw recently a video about
these kits do you know if that's um on
the the State Fire standards website or
if that's on YouTube I think I don't I
we are our chief of EMS that's here okay
all right could be if you Google so the
American College of Surgeons has
something called stop the bleed and
that's where this is the public
initiative this is the New Hampshire
version of that some states have done
this differently and we are one of them
so if you Google stop the bleed you can
actually see this yes thank you for your
questions
thank you madam chair good afternoon
Senator uh you started your speech
saying that you were aiming at select
but not all buildings
um could you Enlighten us as to which
buildings would not be included in this
so what thank you for the question
representative schuett um
there are over 5 000 buildings between
ones that are owned by the state and one
and space that is leased by the state
so in an effort
to get these rolled out but I worked
with administrative services to identify
to really 221 of the most high traffic
you know public and as well as employee
buildings that would be best suited
bless you and that's where we would
start so this committee would make the
decision using the funding that they had
to and these 221 buildings what the
criteria is and where they would start
placing them and it is my hope and
that's why I set up the fund that we can
we can even receive private dot you know
we can receive grants and other ways to
build this out you know there are
seasonal locations that have campgrounds
that would actually probably be great
places for this but there isn't somebody
there throughout the year so we're going
to have to approach this in a tiered
representative blackis thank you
um I noticed you have something here
about replacement and I know these
things don't last forever
um so do you have some estimate as to
what the ongoing costs will be of
handling uh regular replacement of these
so thank you for the question
it's somewhere between 23 and 83 dollars
depending on that's our estimate
depending on what if you buy a pre-made
kit or you put it together yourself it's
not an annual they don't none of this
equipment
none of this equipment expires so but
you would still you know over time if um
you know like rubber gloves can become
kind of they can become fragile if
they're they're not replaced so you know
the building we'd have to work with the
buildings to make sure that they um you
know that they check these just like
they do their aeds that everything is
there that's supposed to be so there
isn't a specific replacement cost I
would estimate as being just what the
initial purchase price
so do you have a general feel for how
long they'd have to go without
replacement I mean I actually
I'm familiar with this I have them in
our vehicles
um and I know they last quite a while
but not forever yeah so just trying to
get a feel if I thank you um for the
question representative Lucas I don't
have an exact place I can point my
finger one of my um colleagues that's
here with me may be able to oh all right
thank you
other questions representative carehart
thank you madam chair
I'm so just to explain where I'm coming
from I saw a video over the weekend of
somebody who's stabbed to death out in
Vancouver out from a Starbucks just
completely random but what I'm concerned
about is we have the materials but we
don't have the training and is there
anything in place to kind of train
people I don't know maybe something in a
school or is there any kind of long-term
plan for something like that because
it's all good to have the stuff there
but if nobody knows how to use it I
understand as a such as a a poster
that's enclosed in each kit but I mean
somebody's bleeding out and you're
reading instructions that could be kind
of
so I don't know if there's any plans
though or that was kind of beyond the
scope and thank you for your question
so in approaching this uh you know again
looking back on the the defibrillators
in the early days
we thought we as EMTs were the only ones
that could do this and then we found the
technology to make it easy and the
public intuitively is able to pick these
machines up and use them so this is
framed in the same way and I know like
looking at a card
um you know it could it could take a
couple seconds to get yourself through
that but how intuitively the public has
been able to already do this so we're
building upon that and you know it would
be ideal that we could
how you know I don't want to mandate
training I want to put this out there in
the same way that we've done other
things and then have people rise to the
occasion and say you know well we're you
know say it in the state house you have
now and that you have these trauma kits
and this is what's in them and this is
how to use them and make it just just
put them near the aeds and you would get
that basic information so my fear is if
that we mandate it it'll hold up getting
these out there and that we we do this
and then rise to the occasion thank you
for your question
other questions representative build
thank you madam Sharon thank you
representative Cronus I just remembered
it was
um at the New Hampshire Historical
Society Library they have a kit and
there was a poster with it so I wanted
to reassure representative Gerhard it
was so informative looking over that
little piece of paper in the coat room
at the New Hampshire Historical Society
I thought I had watched an entire
educational video about it thank you
I have a question
um
why I understand drama kids are good to
have where there's a lot of people
run coming in and out but
why why is this necessarily to be
mandated
well putting them in the building if we
if we want to lead and we know this is
the third leading cause of death and we
want to lean into and give people just
like we have aeds in these buildings
why you know this is the opportunity so
to get something started this is where
we are
I see thank you other questions
all right
thank you senator
thank you and do you have a clerk I can
give the letter to
let's we'll pass it around but I think
you
okay I don't have any other cards is
there anyone else who wishes to testify
good morning committee Madam chairman
[Music]
um
I'm Mark pru representative of
Manchester Hillsboro 15. and a former
member of this committee my favorite
committee
um
didn't really plan on
um speaking but I am a co-sponsor of the
bill and I'm also a stop to bleed
instructor and and that you can usually
get that instruction fairly uh
inexpensive or sometimes free
but I will tell you that I am also an
EMT I teach uh tactical EMS as well and
um
have seen
either in video or in real life these
bleeds and if there is an equipment
people can die in less than five minutes
in some cases but usually the average is
five so having these available is uh
almost as important as the AED
so I think by pushing them out into
state buildings where people can see
them
it at least raises awareness and maybe
they will go get the training on their
own but I know there's a lot of people
floating around because
stop the bleed is similar to teaching
CPR to the general public and a lot of
public take these courses they have the
knowledge they just may not have the
equipment on them when they run into one
of these so having that available
representative Gould
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question I'm assuming that um
so like CPR you use that example and I
working on a person who wasn't breathing
and so I was getting instruction from
the 911 operator over the phone so I'm
assuming in a situation like this if
that kid's available somebody calls
9-1-1 that um that with this kind of a
coordinated effort that you've been
doing all over the country that the 911
operators would be able to help give
people instructions is that true thank
you for bringing that up it is
absolutely true they have a uh flip
charts that can get to the specific
injuries and they can absolutely coach
you through putting on a tourniquick
just seal or or an emergency bandage
absolutely
other questions
all right thank you
representative
thank you so much for the opportunity to
speak with you today in support of this
bill my name is Alexandra Briggs I'm a
resident of lyme New Hampshire and I'm a
trauma surgeon here in New Hampshire I'm
also a instructor for the stop the lead
course which you've heard about already
which prepares people on how to control
baiting and how to save lives
as you've already heard bleeding is the
number one cause of preventable death
after injury and people can
unfortunately bleed to death in as
little as five minutes and that's before
any type of Emergency Services would be
available to arrive
by placing trauma kits in places that
are available to the people present at
the time of an injury
you are providing an opportunity to save
a life
using the contents of the kit to stop
bleeding and to allow an injured patient
to get to definitive care like a care by
myself or one of my colleagues is what
they ultimately need but you would be
able to help bystanders do this
immediately
publicly available instructions are easy
to follow the posters that are available
from the stop the bleed kit and from
other organizations as you've heard
many hospitals in our state and other
organizations provide stop libid
training for very little cost or even
free and it usually takes 60 to 90
minutes to go through one of these
courses and be prepared to stop the
bleeding while we'd all hope that these
kids would be very rarely used of course
emergencies do happen and it's
emergencies of all kinds it's not just a
shooting situation or a bombing
situation it's an accident in the
kitchen as someone's cutting a bagel in
the morning or glass breaking or falling
any of those things can happen
and so you know giving everybody the
opportunity to help a colleague help a
friend help a family member another
person in the public to help save their
life is exactly what you'd be able to do
by placing these kits in public areas so
I appreciate your attention and the
ability to speak today and I'm happy to
take any questions that I might be able
to answer for you okay
thank you are there any questions yeah
representative Schmidt
thank you madam chair
uh thank you Dr uh I experienced not
myself personally on my own body but I
experienced one of these incidents of
15 or 20 years ago when a cousin of mine
had a glass pause of some sort that fell
off of a shelf and and broke on the way
down and and hit her in the in the arm
someplace and the blood was just so I'm
sure that if I had not been there she
would have led to death because
she was that hand was completely
immobilized
um and I had no idea what to do except
but put a plastic
uh red wrapper I think over her hand so
it wouldn't bleed on the floor got her
into her car and went looking for a some
kind of an emergency this was in Fort
Wayne Indiana
but but I and I know what it's like to
see the blood gushing uh and so uh is it
is the instruction worth mandating uh so
that we would have an idea what to do in
addition to having the kit
or is it because like the Heimlich
maneuver kind of everybody's heard of it
I never had to try it that but is it is
it simple instruction that every House
member should have
I think it would be wonderful if
everybody had that instruction I think
mandating anything is very difficult but
certainly encouraging people to get
informed about it as was mentioned
previously if you go to you know sites
like the American College of Surgeons
who have the stopwee program you can
watch a video at home and get all of
this knowledge just from watching it on
your phone or on your computer and then
go to a skill session to be able to
practice it so it's something that's
very easy to have access to and I would
love to encourage everybody to become
knowledgeable about you know we live in
a state where people are active out in
the woods people hunt people hike people
do plenty of activities where these
types of incidents can happen and so the
more people that know how to help the
better I think people's instincts kick
in quickly as they did for you and the
situation that you were in but having
that extra piece of knowledge and then
with this legislation having additional
supplies available to help is always
helpful
thank you
all right thank you Dr Briggs thank you
all right we have uh
the head of the EMS division here in
case there are questions are there
questions
okay you're not seeing any I think
you've answered them very well
oh wow
all right
is there anyone else who wishes to
hey not seeing any help close the
hearing
representative goalie has a motion if
you want to move to Executive session
okay represent goalie
thank you madam chair Madam chair I'd
like to move ought to pass on Senate
sure
being a retired firefighter and working
in the field of Ems for uh 32 and a half
years I have seen numerous occasions
where
kids like these
when they're available
produce results and save lives
I think
it's another tool along with the AED
that can be used
if placed properly around the state
and when needed are available
there will be cards available to help
show with instructions but I think an
important point was brought forward by
representative Gould that when someone's
calling 9-1-1 those operators are
trained to direct someone on how to use
these and how to properly apply a
as always when you have a major bleed
incident time is of the essence and will
save lives and when I look at the cost
um
this is
put forward and I know we're not here to
deal with the cost we're here to deal
with the policy
they're looking at 340 to 440 locations
we heard it would be 200 plus locations
and I think
when you look at
the cost I mean I did a quick look up of
already put together kit with all the
items on here was 99 and I think if it
was done
by the state you could do it at a
substantial savings and even in buying
bulk so when you look at that it's
roughly twenty thousand dollars is
probably the initial cost and when we
talk about saving lives I think it's a
very good investment for the state thank
you
thank you representative Schmidt
thank you madam chair well
excuse me so I've already related the
incident that occurred to my cousin when
I was standing right there and saw it
happen uh and luckily uh uh I was there
otherwise she probably would have bled
to death
but I I knew nothing about the
tremendous speed
that such an incident can can wind up
being fatal in
um so I I think that it's not only the
400 of us that could benefit from the
knowledge and and having the kid
available but also there are members of
the public who come to our committee
meetings and whether it but be by
potentially
an actual attack by someone with a knife
but we read virtually every day in the
paper about stabbing incidents that
happened especially in other countries
but but even in an accident can be just
as fatal if you don't have an immediate
recourse to
First Aid so I I think this is just like
we have
an AED someplace in the building uh
but but uh but this guy this is such a
simple thing the knowledge and a simple
kit
I I think it's like so many other things
okay representative thank you not
usually a big fan for spending money but
I'm I'm going to support this
um I mean my experience is I'm a Farms
instructor and a range safety officer
I've spent some thousands of hours
running ranges and I've always had a kit
quite a bit more than what what this is
um the other thing on people needing
training if a lot of restaurants have a
thing stuck up on the wall that's a kind
of pictorial thing on how to do the
heimlich maneuver I would suggest when
they do this they do something similar
so there's like a durable placard or
something along with the kit and people
who are just wandering by May glance at
it people are going to pick up
information even though you know they'll
have some idea and I think that'd be a
good idea I certainly looked and read at
the ones in restaurants for the Heimlich
maneuver so
um I think I wouldn't want to mandate
this on you know private businesses or
anything but this is a state taking
responsibility for safety in our
building so I could support this all
right other
other comments questions
representative Simon are you uh just
twiddling
fair enough we'll all twiddle together
careful with that thing we don't have
still ties are pretty good no problem
archery application so anyway that
quality
instructions and it's very easy so the
placards are great and they're me and
all the kids but everybody calls the
same place for 9-1-1 because we have the
pizza and all those operator are trained
to provide that truck oh good to know we
need advice in a hurry call 9101 and
they'll help us figure it out
all right anyone else
okay not seeing any more discussion the
motion is ought to pass by
representative goalie and the clerk and
representative Simon yes representative
lakis yes representative Bailey yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative yes
representative Gerhard yes clerical GS
representative Grotto yes representative
Schmidt yes representative goalie yes
representative schuett yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
and the chair
yes
16 a zero name all right the motion
passes 16-0 is there any objection to
consent
all right we'll put this on consent
and when they form that advisory
committee you could certainly recommend
to The Liquor Commission that they
should cover this out of their own
budget
I mean if the liquor stores are one of
the top priorities they are definitely a
1 30 and with perfect timing
I'm going to open the hearing on Senate
Bill 207 and I don't have anybody who
plans to testify on it uh Senator yes
Jason
foreign
okay good morning Madam chair and
members of the committee for the record
I am Senator Rebecca Perkins quoka
representing Senate District 21 the city
of Portsmouth and several Seacoast
communities
SB 207
um an act establishing a committee to
study licensure mental health
professionals and relatives to mental
health critical incident intervention
and management we'll do two things
recreate a study committee I chaired to
examine the state of licensure of mental
health professionals as well as make a
technical correction to the EMS critical
incident intervention and management
statute at the request of the first
responder PTSD Commission
the 2022 study committee which
representative gerd who joined me on
um learned that the licensure of mental
health professionals is very complex
multi-layered issue that we
unfortunately did not have time to fully
explore we did make several
recommendations for legislation which
have been filed this year but there is
further opportunity to study aspects of
this urgent challenge including
reviewing licensure criteria for mental
health professionals regulated by
various state boards including how such
criteria relates to the requirements at
neighboring states
review the licensor process including
how the statutory and Regulatory
framework may impact the timely and
efficient licensure of qualified
applicants identifying and making
recommendations for joining available
licensure compacts or adopting an
endorsement model regarding mental
health professionals
exploring licensure barriers to
attracting
qualified mental health professionals to
New Hampshire and ensuring that the
successful elements of 2020 emergency
orders 8 15 and 18 have been
incorporated into our statute another
year study will hopefully enable the
legislature 2024 to bring the remainder
of the legislation that would address
this urgent topic
um and to address the EMS critical
incident intervention
the amendment that was brought forth in
the Senate by Senator Birdsall is merely
to allow for peer-to-peer support within
the PTSD groups and the volunteer
organizations that support our First
Responders so with that Madam chair I
will conclude and I'm happy to answer
any questions thank you Senator are
apparently not thank you very much thank
you
is there anyone else who wishes to
all right seeing none I will close the
public hearing
and
I don't think we want to vote on it
today because we already have a number
of things relative to mental health
licensure
that we're looking at
um
I'm not sure that we want to add another
study committee
and I
and I think I in fact want to get an
amendment to to split this bill in half
but
I don't think we should vote on it today
yes represent having served in the
committee the original purpose of the
committee was to look at hurdles that
could be removed to allow
um
more mental health professionals in our
state and as a result of that City
committee we came up with some some
ideas but there were so there were so
many Suggestions by the different boards
that we thought
it did not some of some of the
recommendations were not in the purview
of the title of the study committee so
that's why we um but we felt all of us
on the study we met quite often over the
course this summer and we felt that
there was enough dialogue between the
study committee and those testifying
that we should continue it but this is
of course before all this work with
House Bill 655 and House Bill 2 came and
so I agree that we should wait and just
see how all this this shifts out in Edna
because we've got quite a load of stuff
to look at in our committee so I agree
um and I'm not you know I although I
value what the committee does and I
think that there's more work to be done
but let's see what we can accomplish
yeah between ourselves first well and
also the timing is such that
it's easier for us to work on it we
could start tomorrow if we wish
then wait for a committee to be formed
so right
yes representative right I agree I mean
we'll have to see how things go it we
have a retained bill that we're planning
on using for uh
possible changes to Mental Health
licensing and depending on the timing of
everything it might make sense even to
retain this until we're done with that
and deal with them together possibly not
making a motion today but yeah we'll get
something to think about yeah we'll keep
it in in the back of our heads until
we're
uh yes representative so representative
Lucas and I have have spoken and um
since he's going to be the chair of the
subcommittee looking at the mental
health boards and I'm going to be
looking at House Bill 655 at House Bill
2. we thought we would have our our
subcommittee meetings back to back so
that if someone wanted to stay for both
and we could use lots of help so we're
hoping that you'll all participate
I just want to add that thank you for
having the peer support definition put
in there I know for many of my
constituents that has been a really
important component in the big picture
of mental health in New Hampshire
yeah well representative Schmidt thank
you madam chair well you've already
spoken about uh the idea of of uh having
an amendment to split the bill in half I
I agree with what's been said up to this
point with regard to the first aspect uh
but this mental health critical incident
intervention is clearly something that
you see as separate and potentially
doable uh and if we have some
discussions about what it involves
then uh I think we should start because
I I don't I mean I can imagine the words
mean something to me but I don't have a
vivid image of how this would look in
reality well I think we yes we can talk
about it and I'm unless something comes
up to indicate that we need
a specific study committee
I plan to
just leave the peer-to-peer work in the
bill and try and pass it and I'll do
that before the deadline
bring it to the committee for their uh
review sounds like a plan thanks
one else all right we have
we are just too efficient
the final hearing is at 2 15 so I hope
most of you will return
it's a quick question I picked up all
the stuff that was lying on the table at
the beginning of the day but I whine
I wind up with uh uh
Senate built 105 which is not on the
agenda and no 53 which is so what's
going on
our assistant reports that she is
Distributing the Senate bills as she
gets them uh-huh
so we we don't have 53. apparently not
two times wait a minute some people have
prepared statement uh you're gonna if
um thank you other questions
I have a couple uh representative true
you can go first thank you madam chair
and thank you for taking my question so
if the USC says you may use these
refrigerants
um it's it's actually it's the this
current version of the state's building
code is what's prohibitive in this case
because most States operate operate on
like a three-year building code adoption
cycle some operate on Sixth year some
don't even have a State Building Code
altogether and so
um when they're adopting new verses of
building codes they're using the latest
ICC model codes that come out and these
new refrigerants aren't listed in until
the 2024 Edition that just came out from
the ICC this year so what this is doing
is basically just kind of getting a
bridge giving a bridge to manufacturers
here in New Hampshire and otherwise to
get them until get them to the point
where those codes will eventually be
adopted it may be six years before that
happens so this is just a temporary Way
by going into the building code itself
to make sure we're smooth transition
thank you uh I have some questions so
these are these alternate refrigerants
are in the 2024 building codes yes ma'am
chair okay and we are in the 18
considering going to 2021
all right
um
I've got some
correspondence from the State Fire
Marshal and the building code review
board who are very concerned that the
these refrigerants are much more
flammable than the current versions
so low gwp refrigerants which is what we
refer to these refrigerants as low
Global boring potential
um you are they are they are flammable
it's a low flammability rating we refer
to them as a2ls so that's the second
lowest uh flameability rating that these
refrigerants could be given
um
we uh invested over seven million
dollars in Safety Research on these
refrigerants
and the research findings have been used
to upgrade the safety standards and to
protect our customers and stakeholders
more than uh 80 percent
to to
couple it to another industry over 80
percent of the of the cars that are
being sold right now in the U.S are
using these same refrigerants in their
air conditioning systems
um so we um again have uh training
materials developed by the fire service
and we are coming up with a new
curriculum to give to contractors to
make sure that they safely handles up
suit refrigerants
okay
um I'm concerned about
residences because in box in commercial
too in most cases your refrigerators are
right next to your stoves
and so if you had a refrigerant leak
you're exposed to Fire and
are there additional requirements that
are generated by virtue of this like
sprinklers or fire suppression systems
or whatever
no they're uh nothing fire suppression
related
um but obviously as the as the new 2024
codes come out they're going to have
relevant safety standards relevant
Federal safety standards on how to you
know install them how to maintain them
how to safely manage these refrigerants
so do you want us to allow them without
that sort of information
uh no they have as as this as the 2024
ICC codes come out they are tied to
Federal Regulations as well as common
engineering ashrae
um standards that are there for safety
measures
and are those codes available now yes
thank you other representative Schmidt
thank you madam chair so uh our hfcs
flammable
uh they are mildly flammable these are
more flammable but to put in perspective
they have the new a2l refrigerants have
about the same flameability as like
olive oil so if you really hold a torch
to it you know you could eventually get
it to ignite but it's not something that
just you know with one spark you know
can cause a disaster it's it would have
to take a sustained flame on this
refrigerant in order to get to well the
thing is that this stuff is gonna is
gonna be a gas in the system or is there
going to be a liquid in the system the
new the new chemicals yep it's a liquid
it's a liquid in other words it's not
out there as a gas you know
no no no no yeah it is it is and it
operates in a closed system
um and
um you know obviously when there are
leaks they're usually small especially
on a residential scale
um but again the flammability is
considered low and this all goes through
when these new refrigerants are
manufactured they have to go through not
only the EPA but they have to go through
um uh OSHA as well to be checked for
safety standards for use in commercial
applications so there's multiple
agencies and multiple bodies working on
the safety aspects and the ins you know
safe installation of these follow-up
Madam chair so the thing is this is the
committee that handles the building
codes when they come uh into the
legislature for approval so we have a
number of members who have experience
with some of these things and so we have
some level of of sophistication with
regard so I mean grain dust for example
uh is explosive there are things that
are explosive and you're telling me that
this that closed system and it's going
to be in there as a liquid and therefore
it's not gonna if it the chairs ask
about what if there's a leak well if
there's a leak it's going to be as a
liquid and not as a as a gas in other
words
uh it could be well
the new refrigerants can be either
liquid or they could be gas but most
common application and residential
applications is is
um is a coolant type refrigerant
okay well defer to my colleagues for
further questions represent icus
um thank you so are you saying that at
you know standard pressure and room
temperature this stuff is a liquid I'm
skeptical about that no I mean so if it
leaked out into the room would it leak
out
as a either a gas or as a liquid that
would boil into a gas at standard room
conditions yes it it could again but
it's not it's not explosive that's the
that's the key it's not this is an
explosive gas or liquid it's flammable
and the a2l designation that's given to
it
um by the federal government indicates
that 2L means the second low
flammability rate there's a 1l 2L and it
keeps moving up from there so thank you
okay thank you represent Broda
okay so I think you just confirmed so
the material is rated as a two a2l so
considerations for fire safety and for
installation so how do we know that by
inserting this
how do we know that our current building
codes take into consideration those
safety measures if we're going to allow
that refrigerant so the the codes refer
to existing
standards and existing so I mentioned
ashrae standard 90.1 is the is the um
yeah I should like to point out that in
New Hampshire we cannot say that we're
going with the current version of
anything we have to explicitly approve a
specific edition of a rule or regulation
or a standard before we can put it into
law so that
you may this this
standard may or may not be what's in our
current building code
and if it is not it needs to be
officially added to our building code
yes it and it will be we work on the
regulatory side as well you know to the
reason why we pursued legislation in
certain States just because the building
code cycle isn't lining up with the
federal phase down so there are some
states where right now we're just
working through traditional building
code process because
um it just happened to line up that way
but New Hampshire is not one of those
States in fact I'm working in 27 this
year getting prepared for this
transition that begins July 1 2024.
um so there we have a whole regulatory
team that's working on that end with the
safety standards engineering standards
um
so you're if I understand you correctly
you're saying that this is a year in
advance of actually having that sort of
data available
I I guess Madam chair can you rephrase
the question what data
the standards the building codes the
safety procedures Etc will not be
available for adoption or will not be
effective until
over a year from now is that correct
it would depend on when the state of New
Hampshire adopted the 2020 and they
don't have to it doesn't have to be they
could take aspects of the 2024 model
code
is accelerating we will adopt the 2024
building code approximately in 2027. we
prefer to be one cycle behind so the
bugs can come out yep
so
that's uh that's
that's four years ahead ahead of when we
would adopt the building code
yeah so again we've you know we work
with a variety of you know of our
partner engineering organizations to
ensure you know the safety standards are
up to date
um that's a whole effort outside of what
I'm doing
um but what it comes down to is
basically you know the the federal
government is telling us we need to use
these new refrigerants
and they're going to start restricting
the supply next year in 2024 and if
these refrigerants aren't listed in New
Hampshire's building code we can't sell
equipment here and so that's everything
from residential you know air
conditioning units to Commercial
Refrigeration for hospitals restaurants
um it's really put let's put it this way
we're so invested in this as an industry
that we're we're we're trying trying to
get this fixed by the end of the year in
27 different states I'm running all over
the place I mean Maryland right now
Massachusetts Rhode Island they're all
um considering the same legislation
because they're again their building
code cycle doesn't line up with the EPA
timeline
I'm sorry for interrupting you
representative I think you what you said
to me was so if we didn't we don't adopt
this
the current things that were that that
are being installed in our homes and
businesses
those models are going to be
discontinued
well they're going to still remain on
the EPA it's called a snap list of like
approved approved refrigerants they're
going to remain on there what's going to
happen in in practice would be so if a
state didn't adopt these changes to the
code
we would get to July 1st 2024 and they
may not feel it at that point
immediately because there's still going
to be a lot of stock of the current
equipment out there but as you know that
equipment quickly gets bought up because
people have say Surplus refrigerant or
they have you know eventually it's going
to create scarcity and once those once
that current equipment runs out starting
in 2025 our manufacturers can't even put
yeah that was my follow-up so you're
saying that after a certain amount of
time the refrigerant
the refrigerants that we use
in the equipment that we buy now will
not be available is that what you're
saying yes yes
okay well I think
about it yes thank you representative
Schmidt
thank you ma'am chair so did these
issues come up in the Senate when when
the bill was heard there
no uh we had a couple couple questions
but
um again
because we're doing this across the
country
you know we have a lot of other examples
to to kind of show from where this has
been a success like last year and and
not only that I'll note that so this is
one of the rare issues where like
industry and the environmental Community
are also aligned on it right so we have
Chamber of Commerce is one of the
endorsers of this legislation and so is
the Sierra Club and League conservation
voters so from an environmental
standpoint
um the impact is is going to be
significant from our sector I think it's
going to reduce our greenhouse gas
emissions from refrigerants by 75
percent over the next 15 years
um
this also this this sounds good in in
terms of going in One Direction but the
flammability and explosive aspect is uh
the kind of thing we don't want to kind
of go ah what could happen yeah boom
Could Happen well probably not Boomers
probably probably not but I mean you you
understand we have a responsibility to
make a responsible decision on this and
and we got questions
absolutely
um I will say when we're going through
the code adoption process with on the
regulatory side we're working hand in
hand with the Fire Marshal's office
because they you know are part of the
building code adoption process
um they weigh in on all these issues and
um we really again we've invested a lot
of money you know seven million dollars
into training for firefighters for fire
safety public officials
um and you know
again it's it's not I don't want it to
be class uh class classified as
explosive it's just it's it's flammable
we're glad of the difference
thank you madam chair yeah I just wanted
to clarify that with reparations briefly
on the explosiveness versus flammability
there is a big difference on those
issues
um in classifications but I want to get
back to the bill itself
and when I look at this
that as we go forward this just states
that
the product line coming forward
shall not be prohibited I mean it
doesn't say it has to be brought in it
doesn't say it has to be out there
and from what I'm seeing as I looked at
briefly
the 42 USC 7671 code and policy of the
code is
to the maximum extent applicable class 1
and Class 2 substances shall be replaced
by chemical product substitutes or
alternative manufacturing processes that
reduce the overall risk to human health
and the environment and that is clearly
what you're trying to do here
yes and and at its simplest form it's
basically saying all EPA approved
refrigerants are able to be used in the
state of New Hampshire
and so that's basically what the
legislation does just says if it's
approved by the EPA as a as a approved
refrigerant it could be used in
equipment that's sold here and installed
here in in New Hampshire which again
that that
um you know all of the new equipment
beginning in 2025 is going to be using
these new AP um EPA approved substitutes
follow us follow-up please and and just
as I follow up reading this it stays
specifically and I'm sure this is I'm
assuming this has been all through the
EPA as well is that
refrigerant shall be listed in and
installed in accordance with the safety
standards which I'm sure are probably
already
recognized and placed out there for yes
those installing thank you
any other questions yes representative
Bailey thank you madam chair
um
do these new refrigerants work in all of
the existing equipment refrigerators air
conditioners
now
um so representative the the current
equipment that's out there is going to
be still going to need to use hfc based
refrigerant
um all the new stuff will have the new
refrigerants in it but you can't you
can't utilize the new refrigerants in
Old equipment it's specifically
engineered for the new equipment
follow-up follow-up
so for all of the people that have the
current equipment
you're saying there's going to be a
supply problem for them going forward
well there's part of the so this is
going to happen over a 15-year period
the transition and part of the epa's
plan is to keep 15 of
the reserve of these existing
refrigerants in reserve to service all
the current equipment
but the new refrigerants will eventually
or the old refrigerants current
refrigerants they will be obviously
people are going to be buying them
they're not being produced anymore so
whatever's out there on the market is
thank you thank you
very hard
thank you madam chair just curious as to
the timeline these new refrigerants how
long have they been out and how much do
we know about them I'm just thinking you
know government proving DDT and stuff
like that are we actually making the
situation worse or is this stuff time
tested and there's no question about it
yeah we this has been tested for over 10
years now both by our association so our
association isn't just advocacy we also
develop uh safety standards product
certification
so we've we've been engaged with other
entities like ashrae
um is the main one to to come up with
a plan to transition these in safe way
make sure we have all the safety
standards in place and try to make the
transition as smooth as we can thank you
and just follow up and the cost is equal
yes the cost is equal in fact uh only
one percent of the cost of new equipment
is the refrigerant
so compared to previously
it's always been it's always typically
one percent of total cost is the
refrigerant that's in the in the system
thank you okay other questions
I have representative true
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question so
um
how many new refrigerants are there or
is there just one class of new
refrigerant allow the multiple classes
of new refrigerant
uh there are multiple classes of
refrigerants and there's Pro and there's
hundreds of new substitute alternative
refrigerants that are coming out to the
market
and a lot of them are manufactured here
here in the US
thank you anyone else questions I have
one question uh what's the hurry why do
you want it to go into effect 60 days
instead of as of
July 1st 2024.
well ideally Madam chair we're trying to
give our manufacturers as much lead time
as possible because of we need our
manufacturers need to look at sort of
the on a national scale where they're
going to be able to sell equipment and
where they're not and shift and allocate
Supply chains accordingly so you know
ideally we're trying to get them enough
time so we can be sure and have the
certainty that we could sell the
equipment in New Hampshire
um rather than waiting until right
before the deadline when we probably
have already shifted supplies to other
states that are accepting them
thank you other questions representative
baby bear
it's more of a follow-on question to
chair McGuire's question so if this was
not approved would there be a shortage
of equipment
in New Hampshire I think yes there'd be
a short of equipment and a shortage of
refrigerants
that's the last card I had does anyone
else wish to testify on Senate bill 53.
all right seeing
seeing none I'll close the hearing
representative true sorry you thank you
thank you madam chair
did I hear you say that New Hampshire
code doesn't allow us to say yeah
whatever they said we agree with that
that we have to list all these
refrigerants
are we could adopt a later version of
the federal standard which would list
all of the with your list of criteria
more likely
um but yes we have to specifically
identify federal regulations that we are
going to comply with it's in the
Constitution
anyone I don't think we're ready to uh
exec this today do you yes no I would
like to I'm surprised because we have a
pretty
um
proactive Fire Marshal so I would have
thought that if there were concerns he
would have been here or they would have
been here so if there's a way of getting
confirmation I think that's you know I'd
like to see that because
I don't want to impinge
um
you know progress in fact in the way you
know into applying things to people to
New Hampshire but I'd like to know more
about what their concern is and so I
think that's if they're here to tell us
that their concern is you know teeny
teeny teeny then it helps us as opposed
to oh yeah we need to change things so
right so let me think we will send this
to some committee
um who would be appropriate
well your representative Simon your
subcommittee is not overburdened at the
moment
so why don't you take this and make sure
to get the fire marshal and the building
code Review Board in to explain their
concerns
yeah it is we
we as a legislator have decided not to
adopt the latest code as soon as it's
available because there's frequently
uh errors that the early adopters will
find out for us so I'd like to at least
have a meeting on this before we do
anything with it
anyone else
okay well the thing is Mr uruzi is that
yeah so he's obviously extremely
knowledgeable and well prepared and his
testimony was very elucidating but I
think we all have a certain amount of
uncertainty with regard to whether we
shouldn't ask a couple more questions
especially involving the fire marshal in
his office and I hope you will be able
to support our subcommittee meeting
we would we would appreciate your
knowledge all right in that case that's
all we have scheduled for today we are
coming back tomorrow at 10 o'clock
foreign